the white truffle the king of all foods
at the truffle market in Alba in Italy's
Piedmont region the scent of this rare
tuber delights people from all over the
world it's a very distinct taste you
either love it or hate it when you eat
after heat
I don't want to be shameless but I want
more of it
if only weren't so expensive Malraux
Carboni from Alba is a regular visitor
to the market during the white truffle
harvest season fantastic smelling an
emotion every truffle is a different
emotion it's very funny it's very
amazing to go around in the truffle
market and to smell many different
raffle the autumn is my season because
the autumn is the season of truffle the
truffle harvest celebrations in Alba are
lively and colorful marvel Carboni likes
to pop into Tartuffe amaura a truffle
shop founded in 1930 by Giacomo Mora
he had the idea of giving truffles to
celebrities like Alfred Hitchcock but I
wear of Monaco pictures of them holding
truffles laid the foundations for the
cult of the album white truffle
now tons of them are sent all over the
world by express courier we have a good
quality with the best marketing so this
is the reason why I have been so famous
in the world for the white rafts but the
reason is Giacomo more because it was a
genius in the market
[Music]
fresh truffles arrive at the market
every day from the forests around Alba
truffle hunter searched for them with
specially trained dogs when the dog
smells the truffle it scratches the
ground the truffle hunter then carefully
digs up the treasure the real
protagonist is the dog we say we take
the dog down but actually he takes us
and he's the one who finds the truffle
je lui katralla tartufo before a truffle
can be sold at albers market an expert
assesses whether it fulfills the quality
requirements demanded by the capital of
the white truffle getting the coveted
certificate was no problem for this
particular truffle this is a fantastic
trifle it has all the aromas it needs
smells of honey garlic and mushroom and
it is very complex and very interesting
a momentary silent it no wonder it won
first prize in the territory la
competition an important center of the
truffle culture is the Castella green
sauna near Alba it's the seat of the
order of the Knights of the truffle and
wines of Alba and houses a truffle
museum it's also a venue for truffle
auctions where gourmets and celebrities
like Shara Depardieu sometimes bid more
than a hundred thousand euros for an
especially large truffle
due to baggage in a poke first there are
so few of them second people love them
Gomez and experts who really have
sensitive trained palates and third when
you eat them with the right food and the
right wine so that they unfold their
whole flavor it's paradise truffles are
best when shaved into paper-thin slices
over pasta some people say the first
bite is very special
[Music]
I can't eat that raffle not once about
ten times no more and I wait for nine
and ten months
it's very long because at the end of the
SEM Bart and no more truffle for at
least nine months and you have to wait
that when it's a Auto knife again it's
party for my nose
Mauro Carboni and the world's other
truffle aficionados have another few
weeks to enjoy the intoxicating scent
and flavor of the white truffles of Alba